MMM.
Welcome to part three of
native lane.com score.
Send using the international phonetic
alphabet to learn about pronunciation in
language.
This time we'll focus on syllables.
The previous two videos looked
at vowels and then consonants.
If you grasp the basics
of vowels and consonants,
you already have the material
you need to make a syllable.
Vowels sit at the heart of the syllable,
which is actually called
the nucleus of the syllable.
Consonants are built around that nucleus.
Consonants before the veil,
before the nucleus are part
of this syllables onset.
There may be a one or more consonants
in the onset consonants after the vow,
after the nucleus or the Coda,
which is Italian for tail of the syllable.
So we can have syllables with consonants
before the nucleus and then after we
can have syllables with consonants after
the nucleus and none before we can have
a syllable with consonants,
both before and after the nucleus.
We can even have syllables with no
onset and no Coda, just a nucleus.
Languages have different ways of building
a syllable. For instance, in Japanese,
you'll tend to hear syllables
that end in a vowel syllables.
Don't have consonants after the nucleus.
These open syllables have just a
vowel or a consonant plus a vowel.
The vowel can be long or it can be short,
but you'll still stop there.
So the next consonant would be part
of the following syllable in English.
However, we can have open
syllables just like Japanese,
but we also find fairly overloaded
syllables that involve three consonants
before and three consonants after
the vowel nucleus. In all cases,
you can still use the concepts of
syllable onset, syllable, nucleus,
and Coda to analyze syllables in a
language we haven't yet touched on more
complex val nuclei like diphthongs when
we have multiple valves within the same
nucleus,
that's called a dip thong.
Many languages have multiple Val's
sitting at the heart of the same syllable.
For example,
the English word height contains the
Diphthong Iy at the nucleus of the
syllable. There are vowel type
sounds like the glides. Yeah,
and we're,
which I represented an IPA like a j
and a w and Wa are treated as consonant
sounds,
but their vowel like sounds that can
straddle a main val to form a diphthong.
Sometimes the vowel in the nucleus is
simply held longer. It's the same val,
but it's held out for a longer time.
You can represent such long vowels in
the IPA with a double mark after the
vowel,
so the vowel e can be to e I've
been talking about val nuclei,
but a consonant may sit inside the
nucleus of the syllable instead of a vow.
Take the English word nerve.
Some speakers pronounced that word
nerve with an art as a syllable nucleus.
When we write syllabic consonants
like this are in our IPA,
it's conventional to place a small stroke
beneath the consonant to signal that
it's acting as the nucleus.
Okay.
Let's talk a bit more generally about
transcribing speech for a moment.
You've seen slashes around my IPA text.
These slashes are used to open
and close the IPA characters.
For example, this is a transcription
of the English word dashes,
and this is the transcription
of the Italian word Fata.
Both transcriptions are
enclosed in slashes.
You can break your transcription into
syllables by placing a load dot a period
between each syllable like this.
Okay?
These basics.
We'll get you started as you tackle
syllables in any language you're learning.
Join me next time for features that apply
to longer streams of sound and check
out the webpage for examples,
exercises, and more information.